así es esa audiencia en la que se leyó
el veredicto acabo de terminar hace unos
pocos instantes y a la corte concluyó
que ayuda a callan y precisamente este
terrorista marroquí lo encontraron
culpable de todos los de todo aquello
que se le acusaba a la corte además
explicó que había de todas maneras una
voluntad homicida y determinada para
realizar este atentado para matar a
todos los pasajeros que estaban a bordo
de este tren a diferencia de lo que él
había tratado de decir a lo largo de
este juicio que tan solamente duró un
mes en donde él decía que él solamente
iba a matar a unos miembros del consejo
europeo y algunos soldados
norteamericanos para él pues en la corte
los dio una sentencia de cadena perpetua
y para los demás los otros tres acusados
aquí también pues son penas que van
desde los 27 a los 7 años de cárcel